hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the Pandora's box of
molecular diagnostics genomic analysis
of uterine lavage fluid detects early in
de metrio cancers presented by John a
Martin any md PhD we are excited to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by Lavery the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider a virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning on Julius umarov's of labrys
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located in the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
note that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and this offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credit now I'd like to
introduce dr. John martinetti dr. Martin
yeti an expert in human genetics and
genomics sciences at the Icahn School of
Medicine at Mount Sinai as a network
director of the laboratory for
translational research at the WCH in
biomedical research institute under this
collaboration dr. Martin yetiz well
established bedside to bench cancer
research methodology will be extended to
patients at Danbury Norwalk and New
Milford hospitals leading to more
personalized in successful therapeutic
strategies he will work closely with the
oncology physicians and research
scientists across w CH 10 to build their
nationally recognized efforts please
join me in welcoming dr. John martinetti
I will now turn the presentation over to
hem Julie thank you very much for the
introduction and thank you again to you
and to every is for the opportunity to
speak to everyone so the truck I'd want
to give jay is really based upon the
most recent research that we've done and
I've been titled it probably with all
the world's longest title and hopefully
people will forgive me for that but I do
hope something is to be gained from the
information presented it really will
require this Pandora's box of molecular
diagnostics and it describes our efforts
to develop a screening and diagnostic
test and endometrial cancer and really
our success but really is the second
part of the talk describes little bit
promises and apparels advanced molecular
diagnostics and they do go hand in hand
so I do have a disclosure to make swift
Biosciences provided the technical
support in part for these studies so you
know as we think about genetics and
genomics really the 21st century
medicine question is can we provide
personalized or precision cancer care so
you know in this cartoon that I had you
know use a number of women that will
represent them or very similar you know
when you look at the type of clothing
that the right but you do see that there
is one person different and clearly
medicine is based upon understanding
large numbers of individuals and
arriving at a diagnosis surviving the
treatment plan but there are times and
we really need to think about the
individual one person and how do we go
about doing that well clearly this is
the entire focus
personalized medicine liquid biopsies
genetics genomics it's really trying to
think at least in the cancer field is
trying to think about a patient specific
mutations and using that information for
an endo point maybe therapeutics if you
want to train maybe a number different
things but the idea is to treat each
patient's tumor as an individual
collection or data point so we can
understand the mutations that are there
and potential treatment outcomes in
differences in that particular patients
tumor so with that being said that the
lab is been quite successful you can
quite fortunate to work both with
outstanding physicians in particular
period Cuttino who's the director of
guide on services at mount sinai and now
bog and deacon who's the director kind
of here at danbury chn in using CT DNA
so a different part of liquid biopsies
and i'll be talking about today but
thinking about the use of CT DNA as a
biomarker and also the surveillance to
reduce some of the work that we
presented in the past it's not what I
want to speak about today but it does
provide the framework what we want to
talk about and so the clinical problem
we're talking by this endometrial cancer
now endometrial cancer is the most
common gynecological malignancy and the
fourth most common weapons get one mom
living in the u.s. in 2017 this year but
we approximately fifty-five thousand new
cases diagnosed with about 10,000 deaths
strikingly incidents is increasing it's
been estimated that by the year twenty
thirty and anitra Cantrell actually the
third leading cancer among us late now
the symptoms of the infant is with many
cancers are a little nondescript but
there is one particularly interesting
where the symptom is non menstrual
bleeding or discharge
heavy bleeding to Syria pain during
intercourse payment or mass mccullagh
aerial weight loss back pain but again
this post menopausal bleeding is
probably the number one reason for women
to visit a gynecologist and about ten
percent of those women will turn out to
have to be choked answer obviously
ninety percent won't so depends of
diagnostic dilemma yeah the diagnosis is
early then based upon public examination
and neutral biopsy transvaginal
ultrasound but really the gold standard
here is hysteroscopy performed in the
operating room followed by dilation and
curettage which are taking a piece of
that tissue and sending it to the
technologist with their evaluation there
are no clinically useful like their
markers the Diagnostics or screen now
let me as well y ou are a snob ready
we'll base distrust Lee wrote in office
procedures do have failure rate
depending on the age of the patient what
the other diagnostic or diagnosis may be
but where's a fifteen percent of cases
may actually be missed now the issues
with the operating room what is the gold
standard clear this costs is the risk of
general anesthesia there's pain there's
tissue sampling issues and is really the
end of the day the test it's a
subjective interpretive test now clearly
meant Sinai here at don't see to be
quite fortunate have outstanding
pathologists with new experience you
know again depending on where you are in
the world you may not have that luxury
and even within such million ivory
towers there is rudeness diagnosis and
that misdiagnosis are not necessarily oh
it's not but it really is our
understanding than mutual canceled so
the other thing I want to get across is
that the pathologist is not only looking
to say yes or no to the presence of
endometrial cancer but it's also the
type of individual cancel too tight
and this was really a grading system
developing up 30 years ago where there's
a nice aggressive form type 1 and during
the lower grade type of cancer and type
2 more aggressive form whether the
higher brain cancers at the end of the
day the classification of type 1
business type 2 and the diagnosis of
endometrial cancer this really is if I
get movies fancy to insert the work is
really subjective test if the
pathologist experience and the
availability to have microscopic pieces
to cheat look at in to make the hall so
with that in mind I want you to think
about why that becomes important again
with 55,000 cases per year in the u.s.
advising and about ten hundred thousand
thirty butta 230,000 cases or why every
year what's happening is a patient will
come into the office for the diagnosis
they may have whatever symptoms may be
over the list attention in office the
physician must essentially get a little
piece of tissue to start the process
that goes to the longitudinal just makes
a subjective call when they go to the
o.r for surgery or is drugs to be very
very new or four at that point that
subjective test becomes very important
because then it leads the surgeon on the
type of surgery with you whether they go
quite deep to actually get no biopsies
are not depending on whether that the
call is make the Teflon versus type 2
but it will also have implications for
the type of treatment where the patient
just imagine radiation or may have that
your radiation plus chemotherapy on top
that and what we know clinically is even
with the best of value in season the
best of intentions there are always
outliers for example I have services
Nora hospital system asian 361 was
diagnosed with type 1 endometrial cancer
it should have been more denying better
outcome cancer within the first year the
patient in terms of their disease this
is very tight motivation unusual because
it's not will type them to do but with
our surgeons and ecologists it's not
that unusual and so that's what we're
really trying to think about here are
there ways to do diagnostics or not it's
the one we can detect cancer earlier
because the earlier you detect them the
better the patient do and can we think
of a way of understanding that we were
like yodeling the difference between the
less and more aggressive forms of
endometrial cancer comes ultimately
Oklahoma is that patients survive better
and have a better quality of life now
the TCGA couple years with a fantastic
job by looking at large collecting the
collection of endometrial cancers and
they were able to essentially
distinguish not just two classifications
where we leave four classifications and
you see that in the little cartoon on
this slide that it was important because
based on the classification based on
whole exome sequencing RNA seek mutation
analysis you could kind of rank patients
by their survival expectations and
that's if you see on the lower
right-hand side yeah that's fantastic
but if you also go back and you look at
the data which we actually kind of look
like whichever for sleeve and
immediately taken off statisticians
those decisions of us at Mount Sinai who
took the same data so the wait a second
what if we just look at the
pathologist's call and make the
distinction in Survivor going you
consume the to slide via capital my
respond are very similar what one could
almost even argue that just based on
apology fishing characterization we
actually do a little bit better for
taking so long but even if you do that
still not perfect I you want to be able
to say yes no not that likely but what's
important here is that the molecular
does support the tissue diagnosis so if
we can get better with molecular we
really should be able to refine
something and so our question was can
one develop a molecular diagnostic to
diagnose and improve the accuracy of
separation between type 1 and type 2
million trillion cells and the words in
his group actually came out with a
methodology called molecular signature
method not now that we've had the
concept of using a panel to screen and
to use it when you meet your cancer
diagnostics potentially we came back to
our original question it can lead to
find personalized biomarkers and the
whole concept of the study really does
hinging upon our ability to define
panels and the concept of how do we get
material to potentially screen women's
for the presence or the earliest
presence of endometrial cancer so if you
think about the anatomy of the uterus it
really lends itself to the concept of a
lavage the ability to wash the inside of
the years to collect cells and
potentially cell-free DNA that a tumor
may be essentially a mini or a part of
that mix yeah again you're going to
catch a lot of normal cells but if you
think back to 70 years ago this is
really the concept of a pap smear so pap
smears essentially just touch the
surface of cervix and then look for the
presence of cancerous cells the concept
had been tried for many years and many
different iterations for doing this
during lavage but it just never really
seemed to work up until about a year
there were two newly knighted studies by
other groups where they could show that
they could collect some cancer relevant
material from a lavage but our study was
a little bit different our study said
can we do a lavage but in a prospective
matter we don't know what the patient's
diagnosis is but can we look to find
cancer in a patient who has not been
diagnosed with cancer so putting
together anything we've spoken about to
this point here's a little bit of the
cartoon kind of view so the concept of
the study is collecting material from
the robot is where we will collect
normal cellular material normal CF DNA
but also cancer cells potentially cancer
cell free DNA from the vajra process it
we would isolate all the DNA we would
use a panel based approach relief to get
really ultra high coverage 5000 x
coverage and above look for mutations in
cancer driver genes and then compare the
results of the dnc the gold standard
versus our molecular analysis and so
this is the study so the flow chart
showed the enroll first hundred and
seven patients who are coming in for a
diagnostic hysteroscopy in other words
the physician had sent these women to
have a diagnostic test rocity the
suspicion was high for the presence of
cancer but it was uncontrolled and then
we would split the women i would take
via the fluid in collection material in
a split manner in the sense that the
lavage fluid which was being generated
through the history also be at the
pointman mr. Scott was actually placed
into the uterus saline is used to open
understand the newest oldest surgeon
actually has a view inside that material
that saline fluid is normally just
considered waste we collected that
material centered you should put it into
two separate essentially bins one that
had CF DNA essentially an acellular
collection and a cellular fraction
and then we collected the DNA from each
of those and we did our high coverage
sequencing using an endometrial cancer
battle in the meantime and just
following along with standard protocol a
DNC was performed on the women that
material into pathology a diagnosis is
made at the end of the study we then
compared the molecular and the
histopathologic results and this is what
we found the women that were coming in
or a normal distribution one would
expect to be examined for presence of
endometrial cancer you can see the age
distribution the race ethnicity
distribution the BMI in other words
whether these women were considered
overweight obese in because again
there's a very strong correlation with a
body mass index the higher the body mass
index the greater the likelihood of
having endometrial cancer and the
menopausal status about half of the
liver where premenopausal got after work
postmenopausal slightly more
postmenopausal we expect in this
conversation the preoperative diagnosis
in other words going into the o.r the
surgeons had written in their notes that
about fifty percent of the women had
abnormally including postmenopausal
dating about thirty percent had uterine
polyps an actual structural variation
and then you can beat with some of the
other preoperative diagnosis work this
is the panel we started with solar
colleagues at swift Biosciences have a
5016 cancer panel now they have the
amplicons that either cover the entire
gene for example p53 or hot spots within
a number of cancer genes so we could use
this element indeed we did use this
panel for some of the first patients
just to see how much DNA we're getting
the quality you name but again with
Boris readers help we were able to
actually use this panel and even
constrain it further so that Boris came
up with a 12 gene panel and you can see
I've highlighted the genes of my boxes
and we actually added to other genes are
at 18 APR 12
they're 102 epic ons an average length
of about 138 base pairs so it is a very
small panel that we use for this study
this is essentially the final
tissue-based histopathology diagnosis of
the hundred and two women from 107
uncertainty that met all criteria this
list of final diagnosis what I would
point out to you there are seven women
who are diagnosed with endometrial
cancer from 102 that finally were
enrolled in the study six of those women
at stage one a individual cancer that's
early microscopic cancel the grade of
the cancer or the woman had grade one
again very early very low grade cancer
and you can see what some of the
preoperative diagnosis were the age of
the women again would be my husband this
is actually what some of the tumors look
like from the D&C and we went back to
the pathologist that this is tomorrow
clearing in their colonies we could
actually look at some of the specimens
and what I would point out for you and
particularly in de you see that I've
circled that that's actually the tip of
a polyp and within that polyp is the
cancer so initially even within it
within this structure there's a cancer
now when we went back to the molecular
analysis this is very exciting all seven
of the women that had histopathologic
diagnosis of cancer all seven were found
to have mutations I've highlighted three
of the patients here patient 396 or 51
or succeeded color-coded them these are
some of the genes the actual mutations
the mutation class or the drivers
potential drivers and then I've got two
columns here cell pellet DNA and CF DNA
just to show you the coverage that we're
getting and the allele frequency range
so the range goes from about one percent
because
archival NGS so that really is the
bottom of there were things that were
lower but we use the car off of one
percent even though we had a very high
coverage amount all the way up to about
forty percent 38.8 percent here so the
rain B allele frequency range is really
quite broad and as you can see some of
the patients it's actually quite highs
it really made up a large percentage the
DNA we were identifying so the range is
like I the other thing I wanted to
highlight to is that again remembering
that all seven women with pathology
confirmed cancer all seven had mutations
and when you look at the cell pellet DNA
and the cell-free DNA in almost most
every instance if he found mutations in
the cell pellet you'd find it will sell
free but that wasn't always true in a
couple of instances in a highlighted
news by hours and may have found
mutations in cellco it could not in the
CAF or conversely you may have found
them in the CAF but none the cell bill
and again I think the importance of us
having done these two fractions is
highlighted by this kind of an analysis
now the lavage fluid mutations that we
identified we were able to go back to
only four of the actual specimens
because there wasn't enough material for
pathology to allow us to extract
anything for safety purposes but the
majority of mutations that we identified
in either cellco it or the cell-free DNA
were present in the tube and you can see
that by the sum of the mutations are
highlighted in red there present in
pellet or presidency acts they were
present in the truth but again in some
instances for example by highlighted
with a green arrow there were mutations
in the tumor which were not detected in
either of the cell-free or the sub
pellet sometimes we find things in the
toilet not the tumor or the CFDA can
when again this probably that's not
proven probably has to do with the
amount of mutation that we're seeing and
ultimately it has to do quality with the
heterogeneity
of the mutations resolution they are not
proven but that would be a result now I
think that speaks quite highly to the
potential of using this as a screening
tool or as a diagnostic tool in other
words seven women with cancer all seven
annotations but really then the question
becomes what it be other women in the
study so I've highlighted in this table
the final is the pathological diagnosis
so you can see again several ethnic your
cancer but the majority women were
diagnosed as having pilots or polyploid
fragments normal endometrium fibroids
pilots and fibroids endometrial
hyperplasia and other so what did their
mutation characteristics look like this
was really the surprise of the study
half a ball when they were 51 out of 102
in our study population had significant
driver mutations great earring with our
sandals so you can see I've tried to
highlight on upper bar women that had
cancer eliminated endometrial
hyperplasia paula jones one that had
significant cancer drug invitations and
you can again see that some of these
mutations are in k res p10 pik3ca p53
are 18 or anyone so these mutations were
prevalent and they actually were there
in particularly KY ohly elections now
again because this is new technology to
gamble using next-generation sequencing
one thing that was very important for
the study was to validate what we had
done binary pharmacology we went back
and we called about a hard say about a
third one more than a third of all the
variants of we'd identified if the
allele fraction was greater than ten
percent we confirmed in the original
sample of sanger seeds it was less than
ten percent we did DD pcr every mutation
that had been identified by
next-generation sequencing was confirmed
by either Sanger's
agency or a droplet digital PCR in other
words the mutations were real they were
not artifacts you can see by the chart
here the allele frequency what I'd also
like to point out is that when we went
back we could actually identify some new
mutations by digital PCR which obviously
don't know much lower in it's much more
sensitive we can actually use that and
I've highlighted some of those cases in
blue where again we can identify
mutations that we missed by a Jess in
either the cell pellet or CF DNA now
what what did the frequencies look like
it is women that did not have evidence
of cancer by pathology or histopathology
but we were fine mutations well the
allele frequency range really range from
one to thirty percent in averaging about
three percent and you can see on this
histogram the women that did have cancer
we've highlighted those women with these
orangey colored boxes all the women that
did not have cancer we've highlighted
just essentially by just typing their
numbers here so you can see the majority
obviously did not have cancer or didn't
have a diagnosis of cancer but the
mutation spectrum whether they're
driving mutations potential drive isn't
Asians of unknown significance we're
really quite striking and indeed I've
just highlighted two representative data
so the Air Station 395 who had mutations
at a total of five genes 12 driver
mutations the chains affected repeat
npr1 x ACA que rats and fgfr2 again the
allele frequencies were being quite you
know pronounced one to seven percent
patient for 85 who had a benign polyp
for drummer mutation in fact digital of
teaching chaos and technically and again
you'll refraction there's one two three
percent so looking at it it's very
difficult to understand the pattern of
why benign polyp or benign polyp
frightens would have these
nificant mutations in cancer drug chains
now does that mean that everyone that
has a mutation will not develop cancer
doesn't have cancer or doesn't mean that
everyone that has a mutation will
eventually develop cancer well in a
group of 100 women that have undergone
hysteroscopy we would expect about ten
percent to have individual canceled
maybe one or two more percent will
develop individual cancer but fifty
percent of random population women
undergoing diagnostic hysteroscopy
should not develop endometrial cancer
but what's interesting we did have one
patient who returned about 10 months
later who originally Heather's surgery
in two thousand hysteroscopy department
surgery 2015 she was diagnosed are
thickened endometrium we have identified
by driver mutations in four genes but
pathology didn't see any evidence of
cancer asian ten months later returned
bread those compulsive leading pathology
ruthless complex hyperplasia pattern
that the tippy which is suspicious promo
great individual adenocarcinoma and in
11 months after that initial lavage with
that molecular analysis of grade 1 stage
1a individual cancer was through and
there's no more each room invasion of
railroads of cancer and what i've shown
you it's it is a picture of that cancer
so there is potentially some predictive
value in this the problem is the roys
record in the background is too high and
by writing this I clicking in quotation
marks around the word boys we don't know
what that means is
now the only associations we could find
with the presence of mutations were
really age and menopausal status
included tour linked but the older you
are and if you're a postmenopausal we
were more likely to have these cancer
driver mutations you know to give you a
little bit of perspective on the problem
of the power this is actually one of the
patients of seer is what the DNC and
then what the pathologist looks at on
the slide so these slides are all in one
patient's if you look at the second row
if you look at slide number 17 and 16 if
you've got good eyes and you've got a
good video on there you'll see is
actually some little black dots left by
a felt-tip pen that's the patient's
cancer those areas are where we worry
about density areas but we believe those
cancers were the ones that actually
medicines emitted the DNA or the cells
that we were able to detect from the
molecular analysis so the Cowardly
approach is really quite clock the
sensitivity to the technique mutations
is very
in conclusion I'm really trying to think
about future work let me just highlight
three things so I think this study
provides the first evidence for the
ability of an NGS based approach to
prospectively detect early stage and
demetriou cancered again that not to
just keep hitting this over the head but
the point is these were microscopic
cancers detected on centrally saving flu
that was considered waste material we
could use a cow which was designed
specifically for endometrial cancer to
detect these mutations the society also
identified a previously unknown but
highly prevalent landscape of driving
potential driver mutations in women
without histopathologic evidence of
endometrial cancer can remember 51 women
had mutations and cancer driver genes
what does this mean mean when you think
about it this complex genetic
environment what does it reveal about
our current understanding of detection
of genetic mutations in Canberra Genesis
predicting the clinical consequences of
mutation detection and how will we make
patient care decisions in light of these
findings it's not enough just to say yes
there's a mutation yes we can validate
it we know what we found is true how
does that play into the reality of
cancer development in these limit so
just of these last slides I just want to
leave you kind of with a thought and
really business you know our
understanding of the development of
cancer clearly oh and this is a cartoon
by taking food nature of use cancer
article so from the left side and
Pennell normal tissue to the right
invasive cancer and a number of
different issues there are a number of
different you know of pathology or
histopathology recognized features that
we can you go through the entire length
of spectrum from normal to cancerous
tissue and release some of the findings
and
some of the time lines that are there
now that really plays into our
understanding of the development cancer
but what I would ask you to think about
is if we think about the endpoint cancer
and so I what I have is this car to know
you know it's like cancer standing in
the doorway we see the shadow of cancer
and if we then take that cancer material
as we've done for so many tumors now and
as we always do for understanding cancer
development we take those tumors we've
sequence them and we can bring all you
know the different technologies from
single-cell understanding to
next-generation sequencing to really
break down those tumors will understand
the genetics of it what are the features
that are there in that last time point
when we have a cancel and so we have to
be careful not to look back down that
tunnel and say is here will be kind of
these mutations of the tumor so if I
walk backwards whenever I see one of
these mutations I know along this path
towards the development of cancer it's a
revocable when I see these mutations are
leading here but that's really not the
way we should be thinking I would say
from based on our findings an individual
canceled just having the mutations and
seeing them in a timeline does not mean
therefore that you will develop cancer
because again we're finally imitations
and women who do not have evidence of
cancer so it's not a fair model to say
cancers have these mutations if I look
backwards anytime point along that means
if you have expectations you will
develop these cancers it's an it's an
easy trap to fall into again I think the
study really highlights we have
unparalleled technology next-generation
sequencing is leading to a new
revolution understanding our study was
an individual gets but it can go through
the literature you actually seem very
similar sites for bikinis and
chance so again I wanted to thank all
the patients and the families that
participate in our search program
particular people in my laboratory
individual group now the anair over
camacho Venegas in particular Peter to
Tina from the division of gynecologic
oncology the people at swift biosciences
in particular also from the I can
Institute regionalism multiscale biology
boards Reba Bobby Seberg Dimitri ripen
off a number of people that helped fund
these studies and even for a study like
this with only 102 patients really all
the attending suppose the residents that
really helped this study had come to
fruition so it better wanted to thank
you for your patience and open it up for
questions if there are any thank you dr.
Martin Yeti for that informative
presentation it's time for Q&A if you
have a question you'd like to ask dr.
Martin Yeti please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question in the box that appears on
your screen and click on the send button
will answer as many questions as we have
time for if we are unable to get to your
question dr. Martin any will follow up
with them via email after the
presentation let's get started our first
question is is this technology available
for screening women now thanks two weeks
so thanks Julie so the technology the
technology is currently available but it
is not ready for prime time it's really
not ready to screen them because I think
again what if we encapsulate the study
findings we can detect early stage
cancers but we've detected this
landscape of mutations that we don't
understand the biology and we don't
understand the clinical relevance yet so
like an any good screening tool
what you'd really like to be able to do
this pact on the defined in chemical
output and we're at a point where we
would be identifying women who do not
have cancer probably will not develop
cancer and we wouldn't know what to tell
them really what we want to get to is
the point where we can understand what
these mutations and without cancer thank
you the next question is what's us
having a cancer gene mutation room for
the patient well yes yeah that's a great
question and quite frankly we just don't
know yet what we're finding is that as
we look in this population of patients
it's women where we're looking at in
Demetrio tissue it results parallel what
others are seeing looking at skin and
p53 mutations or looking at blood and
looking at no leukemia cancer drugs
these mutations seem to accumulate but
they don't seem to lead to cancer so we
don't know what it means yet clinically
really that that really becomes kind of
point of the larger study now
collaborative site looking at larger
number sleep and following these women
over a period of time
the next question is is this the only
tissue that has been found to have
mutations in cancer genes without
pathologic evidence of cancer thanks
James so thanks Jen so say you know I
guess kind of an answer to the previous
question it's actually not as I
mentioned the answer to the previous
question there are other tissues for
example in skin tissue the skin has been
removed let's say from the upper eyelid
people undergoing plastic surgery you
can actually look at that skin and go
Heatley deep again and it break up small
piece of tissue into small areas and you
can sequence the presence of p53
mutations and again you find entire
clonal patches of p53 mutations but
again when you look at the skin other
than just aged and Sun beatin there's
really no evidence of any cancer present
if it looks like normal skin same with
blood in some of them large number of
studies about four different studies we
have a total of more than 20,000
patients or people do G wall studies or
different psychiatric disorders kind of
as an unexpected outcome there people
have identified small percentage but
still early bird with strong percentage
three four percent of individual that
carried mutations that were known
leukemic driver genes cancer driver
genes and the individuals that submitted
these samples and no evidence of cancer
now that's two examples it's actually
even been identified in a very recent
study that women that were undergoing
Elijah the peritoneum
that were bro barian cancer so there are
two groups living a group with ovarian
cancer your apology a group that had did
not have ovarian cancer when you
actually looked at the peritoneum these
women that didn't have cancer again you
found Peabody communications they're
very well the fraction but that is
probably diluted given the amount of
surface area that's there but again you
found p53 mutations there so my
impression is that the more we look and
one we bring these technologies to bear
in the war we start using very high
coverage a particular area set of genes
the more mutations we're going to fund
it I hope that answers the question
great thank you for that answer we'll
wrap up with one more question and that
question is what next what next well you
know again is trying to be at the other
questions when the other answers are
given recently I think it takes a couple
of different forms i think one form for
what next is really to follow the women
in this study that we've already
identified these mutations over time
what becomes of these women what
percentage will develop cancer event
what other health issues maybes let me
have if any at all so that would be one
important study for the future i think
the other study is really to do a larger
study more within a different gene panel
given what we identified in the twelve
gene i think it makes sense to
potentially open up the chain panel to
look for other kinds of genes that may
be involved in collaboration cells
ecology responds a number of different
things that we can interrogate for
and it would probably make also sense to
look at the timeline of women who do not
have any evidence or any suspicion of
cancer what does the normal and the
metreon look like what do you the
different areas of tissue teachers about
accumulation of mutations if any
relations are truly intimidating I think
again what this study does has really
point out the development of mutations
in cancer genes in what we obtain a
small house we can imagine that a larger
panel to be more mutations but it really
identifies the accumulation of mutations
not just in this tunnel approach that we
think about for cancer but really maybe
as part of normal development and what
are the forces if any neither from
within the cell that prevent cancer from
the rising despite the presence of
expectations or forces externally again
immune system whatever it may be the
environment that could be suppressing
these mutations I think that I think
would be a quite exciting period to see
what this kind of opening of a window in
and this identification mutations will
really teaches long but about the
biology of normal tissue and potentially
a transformation carcinogenic
transformation
I would like to once again thank dr.
Martin Yeti for his presentation do you
have any final comments well first of
all I wanted to acknowledge that the
format a visit and I think them having
travels a lot i think the format is
quite nice and since I people can just
log in and hopefully you'll be exposed
to something they may not get to travel
to hear about and the same to be able
for me to get questions from different
individuals but I really do think what
what I'd like to leave is a take home is
we're really at an exciting time we're
NGS and panels and maybe a lot of the
new technology is really going to open a
new window press from just in probably
the way maybe 100 years ago when people
first had access to x-rays and we can
book inside bodies and you know the
level of understanding jumped you know
incredibly but it also raised a lot of
questions you know but what is that you
know it had normal is that not normal
you know as we got to CT and PET scans
and MRIs you know more reasonably again
it opened up a whole new knowledge base
for not only diagnosing you know illness
but really maybe understanding normal
development and again I think we're
really on that verge of understanding
again you know with NGS really the
application you have ability to do these
kinds of studies we're going to be
opening up a lot of doors it means a lot
more questions than a lot more kind of
you know head scratching and really
periods of vocalists but again I think
this is really the exciting part we're
on the verge of really being able to
break in break down and really
understand things that we've never been
able to see before the genetic side of
tissue growth and development
thank you once again dr. Martin Yeti I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through July 2017 you will receive an
email from Lavery's letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues to me is Miss
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye